bonjour à tous il reste des gens pour
regarder des vidéos sur youtube là parce
que je sais qu'à le beau temps les début
des vacances et où il ya plein de gens
qui sont plus là vous me manquez ceux
qui sont plus là sachez le messieurs
dames aujourd'hui c'est le clasico prévu
ya un seul président qui vous a
particulièrement marqué à l'époque qui
adore un an et demi deux ans presse même
je crois et il est vrai c'est l'un des
préférés après je dis ça à chaque fois
je les aime tous sont tous incroyable
station j'adorerais dit watch paul
dhaille insight souvenez vous dans ce
vrai dire c'est que des gens un peu
choqué de ce à quoi on assiste tout de
ce qui leur arrive
on rit du malheur des autres essais des
valeurs que j'aimerais vous transmettre
aujourd'hui foyer des nouveaux postes
qu'on s'en soit de vote
la qualité de cette vidéo doit être
incroyable c'est le respect des tensions
tu vas pas l'avoir ton père jamais c'est
lui qui les a créées ces petits jeux à
la con qui tu crois a berné on puisse le
père et vaud vient pas il est déjà
devant le match s'est terminé 1 à
regarder c'est mignon il ya un petit qui
veut être le personnage principal lors
de cet anniversaire sauf que c'est pas
son anniversaire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
shaw petit caux vous trouvez que je suis
dur avec les enfants ils l'ont mérité
non parce que l'ambiance allait on est
bien mais je peux la casse est aussi ça
va très vite
on notera quand même ce père dévoué prêt
à tout pour protéger le moment de
l'année où son fils s'apprête à recevoir
une dose d'endorphines et peut pas mine
extraordinaire quel diplomate quel père
pris en flagrant délit au nom les chiens
qui font des bêtises et qu'ils sont
filmés sans le savoir
ma passion au non plus un labrador c'est
vraiment le chien ah ben c'est pas un
golden retriever j'ai fait l'expert je
regarde son visage non de lui donne lui
la vérité et a sorti sa meilleure phase
de chiens trices ont lancé une pétition
aller en descriptions pour qu'elle lui
donne s'il vous plaît l'a mérité on est
tous d'accord ça j'adore les gars c'est
ma [ __ ] passion vous savez pourquoi
parce que je suis jaloux de tous ces
gens qui savent faire des tic toc
formidable moi je sais pas faire via
genre cette tique tant qu'à peine sur
mon compte à chaque type tôt que je suis
pour que ça plaise je suis pas addict au
coeur mais je peux vous dire un truc
c'est que quand je vois quelqu'un faire
un tic tac dans la rue quand je vois les
coulisses du tic toc je suis heureux
parce que quand même elle fait la
chorégraphie je suis sûr que ça va super
bien mais là haut le culot m oh le coup
dur mais étaient dans le rouge
elle est morte de honte les gars même le
chien ne peut pas la réconforter escosse
il a encouragé ce casse les policiers au
brésil fait le 18e anniversaire d'un
voleur est ce qu'ils n'avaient pas le
droit de l'arrêter avant qu'ils aient 18
ans c'est horrible c'est son dernier
moment de vie avant la prise ou aller
derrière les barreaux terminé pour 20
ans mon frère était en train de se faire
engueuler par ma mère du coup j'ai joué
une petite musique de fond c'est très
drôle comme greg meilleur mot par contre
ton frère n'est plus le seul à se faire
engueuler après tout le monde prend
médias cher mais c'est très drôle
non mais regardez c'est encore la vidéo
d'un pape a investi pour ces enfants là
ce papa est en plein gags messieurs
dames via une balle de golf qui a
atterri dans son jardin et il fait ce
genre qui les a sommés puisqu'il est
pris sur la tête
ah oui c'est parce qu'il attend non il
va barder imagine ça t'arrive
il est en train de comprendre et sait
pas quoi faire
il sait pas s'il avoue que c'est savalou
cib en gros bravo papa pour la blague et
il est délégué râle ses quatre années à
l'université pour vivre ce moment unique
de fierté à c'est la remise des diplômes
aux us
qu'est-ce qui pourrait mal tourner et 14
juin
du bridge core
elle s'appelle kerckhof ils l'ont appelé
par jerk off l'un des jours les plus
importants de salaf le public a rigolé
et cette blague
depuis qu'elle est en primaire on lui
faisais la suite on a déjà parlé mais
l'étude des noms de famille c'est
horrible moi à l'époque je m'étais pris
1 messieurs lucas clochard j'en parle
quatorze ans après c'est vous dire
l'ampleur du traumatisme
les petites terrasses ouvertes avec les
jambes millions qui mangent la réaction
de la personne assise derrière la
secrétaire de l'état à l'économie c'est
ça tu as du mal traduit sachant que
c'était il ya un an donc c'était en
plein coït certaine pour certaines
catégories l'alimentaire d'hygiène
ces commerçants continuent à fonctionner
en troisième lieu elle tape à droite de
plein de fer au lieu de l'écouter en
train de faire des tweets en tous sens
et a ramené à la réalité elle tarde à
mener at on de voir ça c'est génial
il ya plein d'unités de police surtout
aux us d'ailleurs je crois qu'ils sont
spécialisé dans un moyen de déplacement
spécifique genre y avait des unités leur
truc c'était le sig où il ya des unités
évidemment à cheval ça vous connaissez
et bien entendu il y en a un vélo mais
un vélo un peu sportif
waouh je crois que j'adorerais que ses
gammes arrêtent ils ont tellement de
charisme jeudi hervé témoin des monnaies
entre les mecs
et ça c'est la réalité oh c'est dur mais
c'est vrai que c'est bizarre de les
mettre en vélo genre un vélo ça fait pas
peur je trouve des quand même vachement
limiter un vélo il ya des escaliers
c'est charles juste au dessus d'une
barrière c'est chao après je pense que
les policiers en vélo ils sont pas là
pour faire des grandes courses
poursuites mais quand même
cette fois c'est l'unité en roller j'ai
même pas quelle des unités en roller
mais là c'est encore pire roller roller
heads up
les gars je suis désolé mais c'est drôle
à attention mise en situation
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est ce que je vous disais légal
barrière ou des escaliers c'est ciao
en revanche les policiers en cheval au
il me met de ses coups de pression genre
je me dis là tu vois si je ramasse pas
le cas cadenas dessous je me fait
poursuivre par des policiers à cheval
c'est relou c'est pas une bicyclette un
cheval j'ai totalement oublié que je
portais des boucles d'oreilles araignée
mais quelle idée
une broche ça ne suffit pas là comme
cédric je dis quoi là c'est très bien
une broche j'aime bien ya pas trop de
trucs à dire non c'est trop triste les
gars c'est un gars qui s'est pété les
doigts et il a la bonne idée d'aller
soutenir son équipe préférée un match
bilan il sait roenick et les doigts le
soutien des français à l'euro tu fais ce
que je veux dire c'est fini l'équipe de
france est ça ma fille a participé à une
émission ou si elle mettait la balle
dans le trou du premier coup elle
remportait deux cent cinquante mille
dollars ou aux incroyables ces golfs
ittierre elle gère maison qu'ils ont
copié le jeu vidéo est pas que le jeu
vidéo s'est basé sur un truc à elle
attendu ce soir
[Musique]
ouais c'est impossible ya un élément qui
fait le tour là impossible
après j'avoue je suis pas physicien mais
excusez moi la balle elle avait quand
même beaucoup d'inertie elle s'arrête
net devant le trou elle s'arrête net
devant le trou et voilà comme elle fait
quoi
lui c'est un auteur qui découvre une
fanfiction entre deux persos de l'une de
ses oeuvres
[Musique]
no vous l'avez maudit à jamais il va
renier ses persos mais c'est le en
dehors de vos fanfiction j'ai touché mon
père dans le mais avec le jeu de la
paille ça c'était vraiment le meilleur
jeu et fit un simple avis
[Musique]
statistiquement il y avait autant de
chances qu'elle gagne au loto mais le
destin lui a dit non non toi ce sera les
petits papiers de la paille dans mais
bravo ma famille a demandé à mon copain
de jouer du piano
[Applaudissements]
ahahah le traquenard le traquenard tu
peut rien refuser à la belle famille en
plus c'est des bons vivants ils veulent
juste chanter qui fait excuses nous si
toi tu joues dans un grand orchestre à
l'opéra de paris et que tu as honte de
jouer pour eux prend nous de haut va je
suis tendu le regard de la défaite à
j'adore les autres faudrait qu'on fasse
une vidéo sur sa d'ailleurs sur les
caméras aux portes c'était vraiment
incroyable ça vous rendez compte
l'ingratitude de ses enfants petit
ingrate
tu te demanderas les doigts plus grande
ce jour-là à tamines petite épine dans
le coeur de ton père et c'est à cause de
cette épine que vous ne serez jamais
plus cher aux canadiens
c'est là qu'est essais qu on n'ose pas
dire qu'ils aiment pas et moi mouais il
veut pas dire qu'ils aiment pas et ne
pas vexer sa maman et arrêter de mettre
vidéos d'enfants là c'est quoi ça c'est
cibler ce parce que j'ai 25 ans vous
croyez que là il faut un enfant
maintenant ça suffit
il regarde autour de lui pour que
quelqu'un le saut à skis ont brouillé
ice l'embrouillé on l'avait déjà vu ça
il s'est embrouillé il en peut plus les
gammes était un code au point moi par
exemple j'ai un collègue mais du coup si
je le dis je pourrai plus faire ou pas
pu faire ce barrage me sacrifie pour
vous dans mon groupe en soirée on a une
règle quand on pense que l'on noué genre
de situation il a envie de s'échapper
mais il arrive pas on va le voir et on
lui dit mec ou meuf t'a eu des news de
nico et si ça répond ouais il arrive
dans 5 minutes c'est qu'il faut sauver
la personne pour la mettez un petit code
en place pour vous sauver les âmes
ça arrive des fois le feeling passe pas
entre deux immenses comme ça j'ai oublié
de fermer la valise
oh non mais ça nous arrive graves
souvent à nous aussi comprendre jet
privé tout la valise défaut on oublie de
la aggrave grave je comprends malade le
problème je m'identifie bien aïe aïe
avec quelqu'un qui se mange un poteau
100% on devient des experts
ouah mettez-y ce métier ce qui me choque
mais qu'est ce qu'il veut faire c'est
quoi c'est le casque
alors il ya deux trucs j'ai pas compris
pourquoi l'oiseau chasse à répétition le
casque est pourquoi elle est là aussi
peur c'est un oiseau sava calme tant lui
un petit peu de concours oui peut-être
mais vous serez pas pourquoi au c'est un
mec qu'a pas vu son chien pendant quatre
mois et qu'il retrouve sa vous savez les
fixes à nous faire
[Musique]
bassoues tu fais pas ça pas messieurs
dames c'est la fin de cette deuxième
fois sur what people died in sight
vraiment bien s'abriter définitivement
agréable en plus aujourd'hui avait
beaucoup de papas et d'animaux pour mon
plus grand plaisir
bref courage à tous ce coin taf d'été et
qui fait bien pour tous et que soit en
vacances je pense qu'on en a bien chez
avec le comité tous ces moments d'un peu
qui fait donc éclatez vous respirez
faites vous plaisir et à attribuer dans
une prochaine vidéo
ciao bonnes vacances et squeeze
[Musique]
et